herr präsident meine damen und herren
schlechte regierungspolitik bekämpft
symptome anstatt die ursachen eines
missstandes zu beheben und ganz
schlechte regierungspolitik ist es wenn
der missstand durch die
symptombekämpfung sogar noch verschärft
wird
und genau das tun sie mit ihrer
bekämpfung sogenannter hassrede werte
regierungsparteien sie schüren erst
richtig den hass und heizen den zorn an
für den sie und ihre politik
verantwortlich sind
damit wir uns klar verstehen ich spreche
nicht von beleidigung verleumdung übler
nachrede oder volksverhetzung die schon
längst strafbar sind nach unserem
strafgesetzbuch
ich spreche noch weniger von dem
anschlag in halle oder dem mordfall
lücke die sie als hassverbrechen
bezeichnen abscheuliche verbrechen die
verfolgt und hart bestraft werden müssen
in ihren initiativen gegen hass rede und
hasskriminalität geht es aber um etwas
ganz anderes sie instrumentalisieren und
missbrauchen diese fälle um ein system
der unterdrückung der freien rede der
zensur unter angst in diesem land zu
installieren um politisch andersdenkende
mundtot zu machen
interessanterweise spricht man ja immer
nur von rechter hasskriminalität und
rüstet zum hasen kampf gegen rechts wenn
es um dieses thema geht die wenigen
schweren straftaten halb ihrer
extremisten greift man begierig auf um
die gefahr des rechtsextremismus maßlos
aufzubauschen und in beispielloser weise
vor allem gegen unsere
rechtsstaatspartei die afg zu hetzen
[Applaus]
extremisten regelmäßig autos
unbescholtener bürger abfackeln oder in
hamburg und bleibt die ganze straßenzüge
verwiesen und hunderte polizisten
verletzten dann spricht man nicht von
hasskriminalität sondern verharmlosen
von linken chaoten oder aktivisten wenn
zugewanderte aus archaischen kulturen
junge frauen vergewaltigen und
bestialisch morgen dann ist auch das
kein hass sondern es sind das
beziehungstaten für die hinteren seiten
der lokalblätter da angeblich nicht von
nationale relevanz minister seehofer hat
denn auch einen punkt 9 punkte plan zur
bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus
angekündigt und der krings hat ihn heute
vorgestellt neben einigen sinnvollen
punkten wie dem schutz von
lokalpolitikern sollen künftig anbieter
von internetseiten auch die ip adressen
der absender sogenannte hassreden und
das bundeskriminalamt melden
eine hotline hotline des
verfassungsschutzes zur denunziation der
eigenen nachbarn als rechtsextreme steht
auch schon bereit hält seehofer sagte
das sei erst der erste schritt meine
damen und herren wenn bespitzelung
denunziation und überwachung erst ein
erster schritt sind dann frage ich mich
was der letzte sein der internierung
umerziehung entzug von grundrechten
worum worum geht es denn hier eigentlich
wenn kanzlerin merkel in indien eine
milliarde euro entwicklungshilfe für
klimaschutz entspricht wer verspricht
während deutsche rentnerinnen und
rentner am monatsende oft nicht genug zu
essen haben dann macht das die menschen
wütend wenn das vermögen der sparer kalt
enteignet wird durch null zins und
negativ politik negativ ginster ezb dann
macht das die menschen wütend wenn
milliarden und abermilliarden an
steuergeldern für illegal eingewanderten
bereitgestellt werden einheimische für
diese ihre städtischen wohnungen
verlassen müssen
dann erwacht ein gefühl der ohnmacht und
des zorns im land und dieses gefühl
wollen sie pathologisierung und
kriminalisieren das volk soll emma haft
erdulden was immer sie im antun bis zur
endgültigen abschaffung deutschlands
und wenn sie glauben ich übertreibe dann
zitiere ich ihnen hier aus der broschüre
der amadeu antonio stiftung ein beispiel
für hate speech hören sie mal gut zu
zitat gegenüberstellung von wir und ihr
gruppe und das konstruieren eines
handlungszwang es beispielsweise wenn
wir uns von denen weiter auf der nase
herumtanzen lassen werden wir alle
sterben zitat ende
mit anderen worten wer das wir gefühl
für wichtig hält für das bestehen einer
nation und im übrigen auch der
demokratie und es ist essenziell wichtig
meine damen und herren
der ist bereits auf dem weg zur
hasskriminalität und muss bekämpft
werden ausdrücklich kein hate speech ist
demnach die herabsetzung deutscher in
dieser nach dieser broschüre wie
kartoffeln oder gerichtlich bestätigt
terrasse weil sie angeblich keine
gesellschaftliche relevanz besitzen und
anetta kahane die präsidentin der amadeu
antonio stiftung schon zu ddr-zeiten als
stasi-spitzel aktiv schreibt im vorwort
zitat menschen denen die und denen
tiefer hass brennen sind am ende eher
animalisch als human das ist auch so
wenn sich dieser hass politisch
ausdrückt meine damen und herren hier
wird den politischen gegner das
menschsein abgesprochen das ist total
etat riss muss in reinkultur und die
wahrheit ist doch dass diejenigen die
von der größten besessenheit gegen
sogenannte hassrede ergriffen sind
selbst von tiefen hass zerfressen sind
nämlich von kulturellem selbsthass meine
damen und herren und nicht die afd
bitte hören sie zu setzt hat in
deutschland wie sie behaupten
wir geben dem gerechten zorn im land
einen zivilen
einen zivilen einen parlamentarischen
ausdruck hören sie deshalb auf die
symptome zu bekämpfen stellen sie die
ursachen für diesen gerechten zorn ab
machen sie politik für das volk und
nicht gegen das volk dann war uns ja
auch keine programme gegen hass rede
mehr und dann haben sie uns auf ihrer
seite
vielen dank marc jung war das von der
fdp-fraktion der in dem neuen punkte
programm der bundesregierung zitat ein
system der unterdrückung der freien rede
sie da